as far as DeSantis goes I think this was
actually a good thing for him because if
there's one thing that that DeSantis is
is a policy wonk and he knows his stuff
he's very technical and he knows all his
stuff when we met with him it was very
robotic and sort of systematic and uh
politician that's who he is you know you
talked about which I think is such a
good point if we can give the essence of
I think your message to to DeSantis is
that the Gladiator metaphors that when
the people win your freedom and I don't
think he's there yet I think he's going
to win over smart college educated Rhino
Maga even those types of guys he's not
he hasn't won over Maga or the people
yet so he gets a b